hello I am Tony Schindler and I work at
Wolfram today I'm going to introduce you
to vicky data it's a large and diverse
data set that everybody can edit and I'm
going to present who I'm going to
present to you upcoming both on language
functionality which you can easily
retrieve and carry that
okay let's start hi I'm Tony I work at
Wolfram and today I'm going to introduce
you to wiki data and new functionality
that we are developing to easily access
it so who feel knows Mickey data who has
edited it before well one person great
so first of all what is wiki data and to
get you an idea let's just look at one
example so here you see an so called
item an item has a number the unique
identifier and it has a label and a
description in various languages it has
statements for instance instance of
which is itself an identifier which has
labels and descriptions and different
languages for instance this statement
says that this item is an instance of
the class of humans and human also has
multilingual labels and descriptions
those labels and descriptions anchor the
meaning of that item across different
languages if you continue you'll find
that date of birth has two different
values probably because different
sources use different calendars so they
might actually be the same values but
different sources claim those different
values and that's totally fine because
wiki data stores statements not facts
statements is what other people say not
what is correct if you scroll further
down the long list of statements
associated with that important item
about Isaac Newton you'll find a new
section of identifiers and those
identifiers include add a virtual
international iter Authority file links
to the German National Library the
Library of Congress the French National
Library and so on
that's a long list and if you go further
up or to the right in this case you'll
see the links to Wikipedia pages and
even if you don't know wiki data you
should know Wikipedia well and on
Wikipedia you see those info boxes on
the right No so where's Vicki data being
used first of all it's being used for
linking different language versions of
Wikipedia but also to in some
Wikipedia's and the communities choice
to populate info boxes and it is great
because some German might be entering a
birthdate of an argentine composer and
it was wrong but some spanish-speaking
person might notice that and correct it
so more eyes on the same data and fixing
it in one place fixes it it in all
Wikipedia's that choose to populate the
info boxes using MIDI data another
application is Wikimedia Commons which
those images and movies and other
documents now and a new feature are the
depict statements that means machine
readable data of what is in the image
the pictures just a first property of a
set of properties that going to be
supported in Wikimedia Commons and the
objects of this statement are terms from
Vicki data yeah so Vicki data has a nice
ontology a huge ontology and you can
pick the terms from that ontology to
annotate images in Wikimedia Commons and
now that you have all of those items and
I'll tell you how many there are
you might want to search for them
instead of manually going through them
one by one now and that's what the wiki
data query service is about now so maybe
bigger
so the Vicki data cursors allows you to
enter Sparkle queries know to search
through all of the data and then you can
produce for instance maps or other
visualizations or Chester raw results
and what about the contents of Vicky's
data so each item that means each
identifiable concept in the world that
the wiki data community considers
notable enough gets a running number and
the first item created on 29th of
October 2012 that means seven years ago
happy birthday wiki data was the
universe and the second item was earth
and item number five is the class of all
humans then there's a particular human
now the class of chemical compounds the
unit meter length caffeine which is an
element of chemical compounds then
another human the concept of physical
quantity a snowflake a movie
the first detected gravitational waves
now skipping forty million items to go
to a scientific article written by dead
human yeah so how do you make
connections between all of those items
using properties and here's a very small
selection of properties that you could
use you know those properties are pure
aided by the community a member can't
just create a property to not spam the
system but usually they propose a
property try to convince the community
that it's a great property and someone
else is allowed to create it if just
consensus no Frances one of the first
properties was image yeah but there's
instance of subclass of part of which
are important for modeling ontology
other famous properties are date of
birth date of death or a more general
property like inception because a
building was not born but it was in
built and then the external identifies
like an ISBN quantity valued properties
like population or mass or the Wolfram
language entity code which means given
an Mickey date ID you can go to entities
and here's a quick overview of how many
properties are over six thousand and
this is a list grouped by data type so
over four thousand takes
identifies that doesn't mean 4,000
values no that means links to 4,000
different databases or websites now and
then items links between items let's say
a person to their teacher or university
or city they were born in quantities
like area mass and so on strings are
important things like time including
dates now geo shapes and how do you get
access to this wealth of data well
there's a new functionality not in the
beta yet but hopefully coming soon
Wiki data search you enter an item and
you get a keyword search through the
labels of the items in your default
language in this case English if you
would include all the languages you
would get too many items now but just an
option in which you can say let me look
through German labels only and this is
the item I was looking for it says
British physicist mathematician yeah
that's the one I wanted
yeah so Isaac Newton I found the item oh
and then I look for the property it's
similar to Wikipedia search in data the
functions that already exist now but in
this case for weekly data so you look
for the property birth date and you also
get an identifier identifying that
particular property and then the super
function that I'm introducing today is
Vicky data data you give the item and
the property and it takes care of
clearing the sparkle endpoint of Vicky's
data dealing with data types even
complex values stored in different nodes
of this large graph in this case it's a
simple case you get a date object but
we'll see more complicated examples so
you don't have to know Sparkle but for
the experts I know and then show a
little bit of sparkle so how would you
very directly the Sparkle endpoint of
Vicky data or in general any Sparkle
endpoint of the growing number that
exist in the world so you specify your
endpoint in this yeah that's this URL
you specify your query
and just a quick comment here so queries
are usually composed of triple patterns
so in this case you try to find all
triples that means subject predict an
object in this large collection of
triples now that match this pattern now
a question mark indicates the start of a
variable and then you find the other
matching triples and then you intersect
them yeah that's in sequel terms join
and then you continue with it and there
are a lot of very primitives in spark
and then using functionality that I
presented last here craft store you can
actually send that query to wiki data to
the endpoint yeah
and get as a result a list of bindings
now they are represented as associations
so this variable item has one solution
this URL now so in the Semantic Web we
identify concepts by your eyes and in
this newer version we use the URL
wrapper and the position is a nice geo
position and you can plot that you know
using Julie's blood for instance so this
map is showing the charcoal powered
charcoal power plants in Germany so I
wouldn't want to live around don't want
I guess but a more sophisticated query
would take on the account which of the
power plants have shut down no but it's
just for the situation so now more
complicated data types well so this this
little claim introduces many more
features so you can have a list of
identifiers in this case the Eiffel
Tower a proton and the particular star
and request a mass for all of them and
make an association so wiki data data is
just like entity value just for wiki
data now it supports the nice syntax and
what you see is you get quantity objects
back which means you can compare them
and place them on a plot yeah and you
see how the proton is lighter than the
Eiffel Tower which is lighter than that
store
I'll show you later what the difficulty
is is that and how it's been solved so
the next idea of Vicky's data as I
mentioned before is the idea of
statements you don't just get values
that are true because what does truth
mean so you get just statements which
means under certain conditions and
formulated as qualifiers and given by a
certain reference that's the value and
wicked data has the model of standard
rank values preferred values or
deprecated values which means if article
claims a certain value and it's later
turns out to be wrong the statement is
not necessarily removed from Ricky data
but just deprecated that means it does
not appear in queries by default but you
can enable it but a user coming to that
item and find wanting to enter it finds
out that well that value has been
claimed indeed but it has been
deprecated so the user learned something
no but you can imagine doing fancy
queries where you find which journal has
published the most deprecated values
whether that is go to bed so in this
case by default we are getting the
preferred value and just the value but
we can say we want a more complete
statement format in this case
Association or an alias for that would
be all no in which we get T value
qualifiers in this case the apparent
magnitude of a particular story here we
get a strong astronomical filter
associated with that value and the
references we had that value was stored
now but yes
yes so the SIRT argument is concerned
with how lists of items or lists of
properties receive their keys in the
resulting fitnah that means if you have
a list of items you get a list by
default but you might want an
association where the initial items are
the keys yeah this option which is a
string current lease or not fully
standardized it changes how each
individual value is formatted no whether
you want more details yeah and in this
case I just say I want all non
deprecated values and I get just for the
single for apparent magnitude of a
single star I get multiple values yeah
that are valid for different
astronomical filters and all stated in
different sources so now let's look for
a moment at the data model of a value so
if I'm asking for the position of health
by Isaac Newton I could imagine in a
simplistic model I just go directly from
Isaac Newton to president of the Royal
Society but that's that's too simple now
so the way the Viki data does it it
starts at Isaac Newton and takes the
pose the claim predicate associated with
position health to go to a statement
node and from that statement node you go
in this simple case to a simple value
but you also go to a reference node
which might link to a book or you might
have qualifies like the start and end
time of this position now and in sparkle
you would simplistically formulate it as
going from the item to the node and from
that node you extract the actual
position to start time end time and
qualifies are not shown because you can
imagine once the note references are not
shown sorry once you go to a reference
it's just an item and you might need or
might want to know what's the label of
it in a particular language so the query
is going to be rather big now and then
you get this result set but you'll have
to format
nicely and in the most general case
there's a lot of post-processing
restructuring of that resulted going on
now and Viki data does all of that for
you in one single simple call how about
time series yeah so now that we know
that this statement format Association
of all we can request qualifiers let's
request a life expectancy for a few
countries and extract for each of the
resulting lists the date and the
Associated value so we can make time
series out of that now and we see that
there seems to be a dip I was surprised
because I thought it would always go up
yeah but we have to run that query again
in a few years I guess so what are those
white boxes those are external
identifiers those are a new construct
that allow us to describe what or in
which identifier system and identify as
valid now in this case q1 is the
identifier within the Mickey data
identify system now we can include meta
information and I think good for
instance the label it is used for
display of that identifier yeah because
just the q1 might be an informative
row by the way we have links derived
from a certain identifier type because
certain identifier types have a
canonical URL now the universe we also
have support for I spin and a number of
other identifies like the musicbrainz
artists ID or chemistry identifiers so
now given a Mickey data ID we can take
those short identifiers type strings or
in case we don't have it just a wiki
data property to go from an idea data ID
to another ID now what we can also go
reverse given a DOI we can retrieve the
corresponding weekly data ID or directly
properties now so all of those 4,000
different identifier types support in
and make it data you can use any
finally we get to entities you know
alpha stores information about how to
map certain entities to the immaculately
IDs that means we can use entities just
in wiki data data to get a nice data set
about Amazon in the river now
but we can also do the reverse given a
Viki data ID we can extract the entity
and then check out the Wolfram data and
there might be a trade off this is war
from curated data and there are few less
data points this is community curated
data there's more but it might have
quality issues so it's up to you to
judge what you're doing and I'm running
out of time so many interesting things
to talk about so a quick refresher so
you might have heard in other talks I go
gave over the last few years about
entity classes yeah and in particular
implicit entity classes in which you
specify certain type and then a list of
conditions for instance longest rivers
in Hungary you you specify the type
River and the condition that it should
be in Hungary and you want the five
largest by lengths well retrieve the
list of entities or make a dataset
containing data for each of those
entries yeah but why stop there why not
just define those entities implicitly
and then use them and Mickey data in
house a house a house impossible to
evaluate an entity class on wiki data so
we have mappings from entity types -
Vicky data items representing a
corresponding class now we also have a
mapping from properties and items so
that means this class can actually be
translated to a Vicky data query so this
is exactly the same type of information
but from Vicky data and all of that is
evaluated in a single query on Vicky's
data so it's very fast so wise
that level of generality why not just
allow arbitrary Vicky's data items in
the first argument of entity class yeah
so this is the class of SI base unit and
I don't specify any condition and I'm
asking for well what's the more from
language quantity corresponding to it
and what are the measured physical
quantities and you see the Candela
that's the Wolfram language unit and
well it measures luminous intensities
but you can imagine that process for any
kind of unity unit so going even further
yeah you can use Vicky's data IDs in the
property position of an implicit entity
class and for instance ask for early
paintings by Bangor yeah get the image
for all of them and make a collage we
are those are the sixteen first images
by Bangor in Big Data five minutes you
can that also works with your custom
entities now so then before you would
probably if you want to curate your own
book library you would probably
carefully enter all of the data in your
own entity store but why actually do
that why not just enter the entity the
label for nice formatting and then the
big date ID and then you can get all of
the data from the key data so normal
duplication of that data in your own
entity store necessary I doubt I will
get through all of the quantity issues
oh that's unfortunate
but yeah just just a quick remark yeah
note how I mentioned simple values
before quantities are more complex here
so once you go from the statement to the
value in this case it's not a simple
value but it's a value note which links
to the amount and to the unit
but units and Viki data are just items
so how do we translate them to warm
language built-in unities well there's a
nice new property called the Morpher
language unit code in wiki data and that
has more than 1,000 values so it means
you can map nearly all quantity valued
data in big data unambiguously
the boy from language yeah and here are
some statistics about it that I can't go
in unfortunately yeah but you can read
about it yeah another fancy feature is
that for instance geo positions might
depend on the coordinate system or a
globe you know and globes are also items
in Vikki data and those items are mapped
to entities using the Wolfram language
entity code so you can get a fully
specified position of something on the
moon now and here's an example of how
this entity code is entered yeah and
anybody can fill in more details and if
they find something missing here
something really fancy that is strictly
more powerful than geo identify is geo
look up on Mickey data yeah so you can
specify for instance physicists born
around oh now that that is already
impressive yeah but even more impressive
is you can use just geo disk to identify
things in that area and then add
additional constraints for instance all
the lakes around Budapest greater than
that to make a map and now that you know
how complicated quantities are you might
be impressed by that query working yeah
you're trying to find optical systems
whose focal lengths yeah or order them
by focal lengths and take the largest
three yeah and those are given in meters
yeah but unit conversions are handled
automatically by that query on vicky's
data it's a single query or you can mask
for the smallest ones and you see they
are given in millimeters but those
conversions are taken care of properly
yeah or the rather simple case finding
the latest movies by Tarantino yeah it's
just ordering by date which is fairly
well understood yeah property pass well
it does actually design issue how do you
represent property pass so what you can
do is start at the country go to the
capital city the head of government
their place of birth and then their
country be increased now so that can be
evaluated but then how do you
extract the head of government in a
single query yeah so I leave that as a
homework one really fancy thing is last
year I introduced symbolic Sparkle or
presented symbolic Sparkle and if the
implicit entity formulation for queries
is not sufficient for you you can use
your own symbolic Sparkle to define the
entity set and get all of the fancy
Vicky data features for free and now to
conclude what is Vicky's data actually
running on it's a software called Mickey
based in its open source software and
some large organizations are
investigating using Vicky's base for
their own data sets for instance the
German and French national library so
wouldn't it be great if you could use
the same functionality to query dead
data and well yes and here's actually
prototype that won't be included anytime
soon but just to show that it works so
wiki base is encapsulated in a docker
container you can just get it and start
it and I actually did that for you yeah
and then you can simply enter the domain
page and create your own items yes
special pages and create a new item yeah
and it's just a Mickey data workflow
yeah I have finished in a few seconds so
I just created a new item that has a
queue number and there are some internal
functions that need to be fleshed out
now but the ideas that you specify just
a configuration define your own
functions that pass this configuration
to those internal functions and then you
have your own picture search where you
find an item picture of a rose and you
can use the functionality like get the
data set you say it depicts a rose and
it's ordered by polar no thanks any
questions
you
[Applause]